attendez puns je vais vous retrouver
j'ai cambrioler 12 banques dans cet état
j'ai volé plus de 9 millions de dollars
en liquide et personne ne sait qui je
suis
que puis je voudrais me livrer aux
autorités
je veut négocier quel genre de
négociations je rendrai les 9 millions
que j'ai volé en échange d'une réduction
de peine
c'est important pourquoi c'est important
à ce point j'ai rencontré une femme
agent spécial
et voici l'agent spécial ni vans wheels
argent
on peut garder tout cet argent pour nous
on le fait et oui elle ouvrait la porte
qu'est-ce qui se passe
son vrai nom est thomas dollars c'était
un mari spécialisé en explosifs pour ne
pas être accusé du meurtre de leurs
collègues
c'est sa jambe poursuivront une me
lâchera ma petite amie elle avait rien à
voir avec tout ça un joli petit je vais
vous retrouver
je veux être innocenté ce qui implique
des aveux complets de votre marque
tous
vous êtes prêt à vous et
[Musique]